they've got him now
the walls are closing in on Donald Trump
CNN has obtained an audio recording of
Donald Trump admitting that he had
classified documents in his possession
and he even read them to his staff
he's a bad sick people but that was your
cue you know against you well it started
right what Millie's talking about oh you
were going to try to do it that's the
staff we're trying to do that before you
even were sworn in that's right trying
to overthrow your life well with Millie
uh let me see that I'll show you an
example he said that I don't know Iran
isn't it amazing to have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him all sorts
of stuff it's pages long you can just
hear the documents
foreign
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly kind of
eventually there's a secret information
look at this you attack and Hillary
would print that out all the time you
know
I should send it to Anthony Weiner yeah
by the way isn't that incredible yeah I
was just saying because we were talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran and what he said
this was done by the military given to
me
and you probably almost didn't believe
me but now you believe me it's
incredible they've got him they've got
him now
this is according to the Liberals and
the Trump haters on the right the proof
that Donald Trump committed the crime
and the evidence that the prosecution
needs to send him to prison forever
except
it isn't
and the way that I know it isn't is that
those documents referenced in the leaked
conversation aren't the documents that
Trump is accused of mishandling
and you don't even need to take my word
for it even liberal CBS News admits it
here we go CBS news headline Iran memo
not among the 31 records underlying
charges in Trump Federal indictment
here's what CBS has to say quote the
document and recording are described in
the indictment Smith's team security
against Trump earlier this month
recounted as an alleged meeting with
writer a publisher and two members of
trump staff none of whom possessed a
security clearance but according to a
source familiar with the matter Trump
was not charged with unlawfully holding
on to the Iran related document
discussed in the recording so in plain
English in other words
the allegedly damning leaked audio has
basically no bearing on the bogus
charges brought against Trump in the
doj's corrupt and selective prosecution
isn't that a little weird
don't you think if the Biden thugs
really had the goods to send their Chief
political opponent who happens to be a
former president to prison in an
unprecedented prosecution that they
might have leaked a conversation that
was pertinent to the case
but they didn't
because they don't have the goods
because after seven years of attempts to
get this guy
through illegal spying on his campaign
through a bogus special counsel around
Russia collusion through an unsuccessful
impeachment around Ukraine collusion
through a second unsuccessful
impeachment around Insurrection or
whatever even after all of that
Trump's political enemies still
incredibly
have nothing I'm Michael Knowles as the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Senator Marco
Rubio is joining the Matt Walsh UFO
train we will get to that
as late into the show as I possibly can
this stupid UFO stuff first though is
Trump
the cleanest guy in politics
I'm not joking
is Donald Trump
celebrity a-lister for 40 years dated
supermodels all
loudmouth also real estate developer in
New York and yet
they've gotten nothing on this guy and
they have been trying the powers that be
with the full force of the federal
government has been trying to get him
for seven years
they've done it now half a dozen times
through very targeted operations they
still don't have them they still don't
have him they're big damning Central
piece of evidence
is not pertinent to the case
that they're bringing against to in
federal court
they got nothing
so what is it is Donald Trump the
cleanest guy in politics maybe or is the
doj just incompetent and corrupt
certainly the latter there there's a
headline just comes out of the doj
Watchdog which says that the doj
Watchdog has concluded
try not if you're driving please pull
over I don't want you to laugh yourself
into a car accident they've concluded
that
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself
say that again they the doj watchdog
says that do you ever have Steen the
most famous
intelligence connected sex trafficking
with minors buddy of billionaires and
heads of state and royalty and a lot of
powerful people he just he just killed
himself oopsie Daisy
I don't really I don't buy that
and you don't buy that and nobody buys
that
to the credit of the Associated Press
they're at least filling in a little
more color there and pointing out that
that the Watchdog did find some
misconduct by federal jail guards that
allow Jeffrey Epstein to commit suicide
but there's a lot of coincidences
the jail guard doesn't take his security
walk the other geoguard doesn't make a
security Walk The One camera goes out
what about the other what about a second
camera a second camera that actually
that accidentally malfunctions too how
did he oh he just accidentally had
exactly the right amount of time to kill
himself I don't think so
now
what does it mean that nobody believes
that Jeffrey Epstein killed himself it
means that our government is more
corrupt or at least more transparently
corrupt than it has been in our
lifetimes and when our government is
transparently corrupt people start to
look for Alternatives who seem like they
are outside of the political
establishment which explains
a pretty amazing poll that just came out
from morning consult which is
about the 2024 GOP Primary and you know
who's number one and you know who's
number two you might be surprised to
know that Mike Pence is number three but
just behind Mike Pence at number four
the vague ramaswamy
the vague ramaswamy is an entrepreneur
he's 37 years old very few people had
heard of him until quite recently the
vague it is a tech guy he
it was written a couple of books
that's it and Vivek right now is polling
at six percent which is twice
the next candidate on the list he's
polling twice Nikki Haley U.N Ambassador
and former governor of South Carolina
he's pulling twice Tim Scott a sitting
U.S senator
he's bowling three times Chris Christie
a two-term governor who is leading the
chrysosons but not nearly as much as the
Ramos ramaswamasans I don't know uh he's
six times ASA Hutchinson I can't believe
he's even on the pole bergam is at zero
Suarez is it zero herd is it zero
someone else that's a candidate someone
else capital S capital E is pulling one
percent so tied with Hutchinson
that's a very impressive number
so congratulations to Vivek in the Rama
Swami campaign that's that's really
impressive and it tells you something
about the time we're living in which is
that if you are viewed to be part of the
political establishment that is a
liability for you one other weird little
bit of color on this poll is a lot of
people are asking how is Mike Pence at
seven percent the way that Mike Pence is
at seven percent is one the man was the
vice president of the United States not
all that long ago the man was a popular
governor of Indiana the man was a
popular Congressman so he's got a lot of
support and he also leans into more of
the establishment side of the
conservative movement the Republican
party and there are still a lot of
people there it's very easy to get lost
with a tide of rising populism in this
idea that the establishment's totally
done and vanquished it's not and you saw
this same kind of thing happening in
1980 which is why the 1980 presidential
ticket for the right was Ronald Reagan
who was the Conservative candidate and
George H.W bush who was the more
establishment
the country club kind of candidate
and Mike Pence who is more conservative
than George Bush is is actively running
in that More Country Club establishment
Lane he's talking about how we need to
lay off companies how not like not light
them off like layoff workers meaning
layoff like stop attacking companies
return to just the same old sort of
mantras and mottos of the Reagan Era so
he's running in that lane and I suspect
what Pence is thinking is well okay
maybe this doesn't describe the majority
of the base right now but they're
Reagan had to pick bush in 1989 at the
party maybe somebody will pick me to be
vice president or maybe somehow I'll be
the nominee as well
now I've got a more important and Urgent
question for you not just who's going to
be the nominee in 2024 but what are you
going to do when you want to barbecue
with your friends and your propane tank
runs out you got to check out cinch
right now go to cinch.com use promo code
knows the Fourth of July is right around
the corner with how many family
gatherings we have lined up the last
thing that I need when hosting family is
turning on the grill and being out of
propane that is where our friends at
cinch come in cinch is a propane grill
tank Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door and on
your schedule and do not require any
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere the perfect summer would not be
complete without singe go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knowles that is cinch.com or
download the Cinch app and use promo
code Knowles kwles to get your first
tank exchange for just ten dollars this
is a limited time offer you must live
within a cinch service area to redeem it
go to cinch.com offer for details then
go to the Cinch mobile app or cinch.com
promo code nulls to get your propane
tank refill now
speaking of reports in the news
speaking of the establishment and the
establishment media
you know we played on the show the other
day the New York City Pride Parade Where
The Pride Marchers are marching down the
street yelling we're here we're queer
we're coming for your kids
we're here we're coming for your kids
and this didn't play very well because
[Music]
thank you
now speaking of what's being taught in
schools
there is a new aspect mandatory aspect
of the curriculum in New York City
Schools this would be mindful breathing
mindful breathing
according to the New York City
Health Department they say today New
York city mayor and Department of
Education Chancellor and New York City
Health commissioner announced that all
New York City Schools will be required
to offer mindful breathing practices the
announcement aims to increase physical
and mental health and enhance social
emotional learning a lot of gobbledygo
what does that mean
it means that
Eastern specifically Buddhist religious
rituals and prayers are now a mandatory
part of the curriculum which is really
funny in a dark way because the Supreme
Court came out in the middle of the 20th
century and said Christian prayer in
schools as a matter of the curriculum is
unconstitutional which would be a big
surprise to the framers of the
Constitution that would be a big
surprise to The Men Who Built our
country as a Christian Nation but that's
what the Supreme Court decided in the
middle of 20th century no school prayer
unless it's Buddhist prayer what is
mindful breathing
sounds like liberal gobbledygook and it
is but it is a Buddhist practice it's
it's called
I'm sure I'm mispronouncing that
mindfulness mindfulness of breathing and
what it refers to and this is by the way
this is just according to the Wikipedia
page okay I'm going to a liberal very
mainstream source
meaning mindfulness of breathing uh
paying attention to breath it is the
quintessential form of Buddhist
Meditation attributed to gotama Buddha
and described in several sutas most
notably the anapanasati suta which I
guess makes sense uh
now you might say well Michael no it's
just a coincidence we mean it's just a
coincidence no they're just teaching
breathing exercises so they're not just
we all know how to breathe okay and
they're not they already have gym class
what is mindful
breathing
well the question you have to ask is
mindful of what
what's in your mind if you're if you if
you are being mindful that means your
mind is full of something what is it
full of
that's full of an Eastern Pagan religion
in this case and by the way the further
proof of this is that at almost exactly
the same time that this announcement
came at New York City Schools announced
that a Hindu and Buddhist holiday Diwali
will uh be given off in New York City
public schools and education officials
will have to accommodate this day off I
do not in any way begrudge the Hindus
and the Buddhists there are plenty of
Indians for instance uh in New York City
I don't begrudge them their day off or
anything like that I don't begrudge them
whatever traditional practices they have
but at the very same time that we are
seeing the eradication of Christianity
the religion that has animated our
civilization and the religion that I'm
rather certain happens to be correct as
we're seeing that being pulled away not
by the people but by the force of law in
our schools and public life you were
seeing an elite insertion of Eastern
religion non-theistic religion religion
that contradicts our religion in this
civilization that's being inserted into
the curriculum as a mandatory matter
because you because you can never get
away from school prayer because you can
never get away from prayer because you
can never get away from religion because
people have eternal questions those are
the nagging questions that keep coming
up who are we what are we for what
happens after death how do we relate to
one another what is the moral order and
education is about filling up your mind
and when your mind is going to be full
when all education is in some ways
mindful the question you have to ask is
what are you going to be filling your
mind up with
and where are you going to go
how are you going to get there when you
want to get somewhere you got to check
out Cars 8 right now go to carzing.com
Knowles buying a new car can be a
stressful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first-time buyer
or have no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the whole day with
crowds stress the potential to not even
find the right car you've got to check
out carsing carzing is completely
changing the way you buy a car online by
partnering with Credit Agencies leaders
in over 25 000 dealers Nationwide Cars
Inc provides you with everything you
need before stepping foot onto a
dealership once you find the right car
at your ideal budget all you've got to
do is bring your saved deal voucher with
you to the dealership to finalize your
next ride it is so simple even if you're
not in the market for a new car you
should check out cars in anyway
karzing's online window shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
dive into each vehicle's specs features
performance capabilities zoom in on the
craftsmanship of the Interior Marvel at
Cutting Edge technology admire the
meticulous attention to detail that sets
these automobiles apart from the rest
harzing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful go to
carzing.com Knowles today find the best
deals near you carzing.com Knowles
now if you're looking for something to
watch
you got to check out what we saw hosted
by Storyteller Bill whittle
season one is focused on Apollo 11 and
now the entirety of season two of what
we saw is available delve into the
origins and key events of the Cold War
as the series explores pivotal moments
such as the Berlin blockade the Korean
War the death of Stalin the Cuban
Missile Crisis the Vietnam War Watergate
and the ultimate resolution of the Cold
War don't just read about history
liveth Bill makes you feel like you are
there witnessing history and all
episodes of Cold War are now available
to stream but you have to be a daily
wear plus member to see it go to
dailywire.com Cold War to start watching
my favorite comment yesterday something
that I'll get to in just a little bit
but I won't get to it right now because
my producers just faked me out and put
it into the prompter a little bit too
early now speaking of New York
very very big news
I made it to Broadway
I've gone to Broadway shows since I was
a kid I haven't been in a little while I
occasionally worked around New York back
in the days I banged around a theater or
two but I made it really big I made it
really really big this week I was not
only featured on Broadway
by the cast of a Broadway musical in a
Broadway performance I was featured
by that cast in that performance on
Broadway in Times Square see if you can
pick me up
or should we consider its past ruling on
a same-sex Fair
well my children
I miss you already
[Music]
can be
I'm also really pleased to find out that
in my performance in this Broadway show
on Broadway in Times Square I also had
the best voice of any of the cast
members I don't mean to be mean to these
performers but when I was a kid I'd go
see a Broadway show
you had the very best performers the
very best live performers in the country
maybe in the world where they're singing
just amazing talent and skill and
that that was not the most amazing Town
talent and skill I've ever seen because
a radical political agenda
has overtaken
craft and skill and art
and and talent
so it opens up well it opens up with my
voice saying that line
and then it cuts to some drag queen
singing off off key and off tone but
hello my children I miss you my children
whose children
not a lot of men who identify as women
who dress up in Drag
I guess some of them have biological
children but it's not that's not the
common thing so what is this you're just
seeing a reiteration a re-articulation
from Broadway from Times Square of the
same thing you heard the drag Marchers
screaming through the streets we're
coming for your children
why did they put my line up there at the
beginning of their performance this is
from the the show parade which I've
never heard of but I guess it's a
Broadway musical
they use that line because that line
really got under their skin
and that line really got under their
skin because it was a clear articulation
of the conservative position and it
wasn't squishy and it didn't just push
the tissue into this area of well you
know we should obviously Embrace but
eight-year-olds are a little too young
we should wait till they turn nine or
whatever we just said no no it's wrong
for kids it's wrong for adults it's
wrong the whole thing is just wrong it's
and it's going to make people miserable
and in the best interests of society and
especially in the best interests of
these terribly people uh you gotta you
gotta
okay
and this really bugged the libs and that
should be a
that should be an important data point
that should be an important lesson for
conservatives
because I gave that speech what in
February or March or something like that
and it was shocking for a moment there
were a lot of conservatives who didn't
come out and back me right away but then
you had a handful of courageous
conservatives come out and say no
actually
I'm defending that line I oppose the
libs who were trying to libel Michael
Knowles wonderful people Senator Mike
Lee came out very publicly uh then a
number of conservative outlets and
pundits and activists and all the rest
then the whole conservative movement
came in and backed me and then what
happened then we get these numbers a
couple of weeks ago that showed that
Americans are moving much more into a
socially conservative Direction
with these numbers out that support even
for same-sex relationships
support for something that had been we
thought settled in the 1990s
dropped seven points in one year
why because if you're just clear about
your point of view and you base it in
the truth and you don't base it on on
trying to please everybody in Focus
grouping everything that is going to
resonate and I think that the libs are
Running Scared on that I think that's
why they're whining and screaming and
putting my voice on in Broadway
performances in Times Square and that's
why we need to keep up
the Heat
it's a very absurd Ideology Now speaking
of absurdity
Marco Rubio I like Marco Rubio
I think his heart basically is in the
right place or at least his his
political mind is basically roughly in
the right place but he's gone
he's gone off the deep end Mr Rubio
because Marco Rubio is entertaining all
this UFO stuff
do you find many of them credible well I
don't find them either not credible or
credible because we have no basis about
we understand some of these claims are
things that are Beyond sort of the realm
of what any of us has ever dealt with
what I think we owe them is just a
mature you know understand listening and
trying to put these all these pieces
together and just sort of intake the
information without any prejudgment or
jumping to any conclusions in One
Direction or another I will say I find
most of these people at some point or
maybe even currently have held very high
clearances and high positions within our
government so you start out you do ask
yourself like what incentive would so
many people would that kind of um
qualification these are serious people
have to come forward and make something
up
what what kind of incentive would they
have
uh Senator Rubio come on
he's saying look I'm not rushing the
Judgment I'm not saying I believe them I
don't believe them they're saying why
would they make it up it's he's saying
the same thing Walsh says
let me explain to you
what the aliens are and I was reminded
of this verse by my friend Taylor
Marshall and a good take on it
great great podcaster Catholic guy
Asians
chapter 2 verse two herein in time past
you walked according to the course of
this world according to the prince of
the power of this heir
of the spirit that now worketh on the
children of unbelief
UFOs are just little things that we see
in the sky that defy physical
explanation
I don't want to just be like the guy in
the History Channel
demons guys it's just it's it's just
demons that's what it is
and the people Walsh aside and this is
what bugs me about Rubio embracing this
too Walsh solid Catholic guy but he
falls into this thing
the UFO stuff the alien stuff which is
just demonology for Liberal atheists
that's all it is because the people have
known for all of human history that
spiritual realities exist and that there
are things that are physical and there
are things there are things that are
physical and don't have a rational Soul
like a rock
then there are things that are physical
and do have a rational Soul like human
beings
there are things that are not physical
that are metaphysical like ideas and
Love and Hope and Mathematics and
Angels and Demons
that there are intelligences that do not
have physical form if you believe in God
let's not even get into the specifics on
your religious views if you believe that
God exists and don't forget the
existence of God can be known with
certainty by the natural light of human
reason from the created world
if you believe and you can there are
many very good Arguments for God's
existence
and God's existence is necessary we can
know that it's true just from the world
around us using our own reason then you
know that God
is metaphysical
God takes on a body in the Incarnation
in the second person of the Trinity
Jesus Christ
but God the Father God the Holy Spirit
metaphysical
it doesn't it's not not just like an old
guy with a beard in the sky as the
liberal atheists try to pretend they try
to pretend that we believe that so if
you acknowledge that there are there is
at least one intelligence one
intelligent being that doesn't have a
body then you know Angels and Demons
flow from that and then of course if you
follow
your reason to say okay I know that God
exists well what can I know about God
and then you turn to revelation
you see Angels everywhere and every
every group of people for all of human
history until like just stupid modern
liberal atheists believed that Angels
and Demons exist by the way the stupid
liberal modern atheists they believe
that too
they believe it when they get in the
foxholes they believe it when they get
into a bad spot they believe it even
when they talk about their fallen
comrades
let's say oh so-and-so had demons oh
yeah a guy who died of a drug overdose
yeah he boy he sure had his demons
everybody talks about it
but now we've got to pretend that
everything's physical you say oh pretty
soon they're going to say odd poor
Johnny died there drunk in the gutter
doing a bunch of drugs and all that but
he had his aliens
oh that boy he was tormented by Martians
oh it's my but they're just there they
are demons
speaking of demonic things the US Army's
Special Operations Command
USA SOC
is promoting
[Music]
but you've got you've got morality and
political popularity in a rare
convergence here so come on out guys say
it with your chest and state it we want
to hear that we got to restore some
balance to our country and when you want
to restore balance to your body you got
to check out balance of nature right now
go to balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients of the fruits and veggies
are preserved so that you can get that
vital nutrition in each capsule balance
of nature is a whole food supplement
with no additives fillers extracts
synthetics pesticides or added sugar
pure fruits and veggies are the only
things they put in their capsules I
really love balance of nature my only
complaint surrounding balance of nature
is that when they send their delicious
product here to the Daily wire the
hyenas and jackals just rip them all
away often before I even have the
opportunity to go look at them for a
limited time this summer when you become
a preferred customer balance of nature
they're throwing in a free fruit and
veggies travel set and giving an
additional 25 bucks off your first order
go to balance of nature.com use promo
code Knowles for a free travel set and
25 bucks off your first order as a
preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
now it's time for my favorite comment
yesterday because my producers have now
put this in at the right time you know
in the flow I don't want to get to that
too early it's going to get we gotta
save that little juicy dessert for the
end of the show my favorite comment
yesterday comes from not overcome who
says I visited New York City with my
teenage daughter to see the sights and
of course to watch and eat a New York
Pizza there's nothing like their pizza
and bagels that's a really true
statement there at the end because
they're going to get rid of it so there
is nothing like New York City Pizza
anymore because New York City is trying
to get rid of one of the defining
aspects of New York culture and they're
not doing it
accidentally it's not just all those
stupid liberals they don't even know
what they're doing to quote Marco Rubio
we need to dispel with this fiction that
they don't know what they're doing they
know exactly what they're doing and what
they're doing is their upending
tradition and taboos and standards and
norms and and they're doing that in
order to redefine the culture because
they don't like the traditional culture
so they want to refashion it after their
own image and feed us all bug Burgers
instead of tasty New York wood-fired
pizza
speaking of shake-ups
here's an exclusive from The Daily
Caller
this is an exclusive that a lot of
conservatives are celebrating and I
don't think they should be celebrating
too soon
top Anheuser-Busch Marketing Executives
responsible for the boycott are no
longer employed
so the not the Marketing Executives who
push the boycott but the Marketing
Executives who pushed
that impelled the boycott group vice
president for marketing Daniel Blake and
Bud Light marketing vice president
Alyssa heiner Scheid are gone according
to obtained text messages with a current
Regional head of marketing
daily callers granting anonymity of the
source to discuss legally fraught
internal company policy
to my understanding if we publicly
announce the word fire it opens up
potential for them to sue us that's why
we said leave babsons but they're gone
uh not good enough for me man
not good enough for me
and people are saying actually here some
of the anonymous sources they say to be
fair Daniel Blake was actually awesome I
think he was just caught in crossfire
but also he did hire her Alyssa Alyssa
heinershide so that's a fault of his
okay I don't I don't even want to hear
it about Alyssa heinershine
Daniel Blake and Alyssa heinershit are
not the reason that that
pushed the rainbow flag and pushed
transgenderism
the highest echelons of a b imbev
transheiser Bush after it was bought up
by that Belgian company they're the ones
who are responsible because they're the
ones who are beholden to the asset
managers and the institutional investors
who are pushing ESG that's why Bud Light
transheer Bush and all these other
companies don't come out and publicly
apologize because if they apologize and
they say we're not going to push
transgenderism anymore then they're
going to have a lower ESG score and then
they might lose investment from the big
asset managers and then their top stock
price might tank
and by the way most of these companies
have signed on to something called the
Global Alliance for responsible media
garm and what garm says is
you've got to align your public efforts
in your company in accordance with
liberal activism and specifically with
the Rainbow Coalition and transgenderism
and if you don't we've got a partnership
with the tech platforms and with the
advertising platforms which are
monopolist oligopolistic at least and
really pretty close to monopolistic when
you look at Google ads and so if you
don't toe the line on transgenderism
then we're going to take away your
ability to Market your product that's
what this is about this isn't about some
VP of marketing
these are The Fall Guys as they say they
got caught in the crossfire yeah they
did get caught in the crossfire and
maybe they played it a little loose this
gal Alyssa Heinrich I mean she played a
little loose but this was a decision
made from the very top and so and until
we see
heads rolling at the very top of the
company or I don't even need the heads
to roll they need to pull out of garm
they need to resist the ESG nonsense
they need to pressure the asset managers
like BlackRock you're starting to see
this weekend over there at BlackRock now
at vanguarden State Street
to move away from this liberal activism
using your money and my money to to do
it
uh then I don't want to hear it I don't
want okay good though the marketing VP
is gone give me a break doesn't mean
anything look I'm I'm as hopeful glass
half full As It Gets In the conservative
movement a lot of my friends and
colleagues in this particular region of
politics are always just angry and
complaining about everything and that's
really not my view but here guys we're
getting played for fools you'd have to
be so naive to think that means they
fired some two-bit marketing VP the
transcisor bush has turned into rent
look what they're still sponsoring Pride
parades give me a break speaking of
harmful powerful social movements
a former Penn State professor has just
told
journalists and just follow the lawsuit
because the professor was told by
college administrators that quote there
is a problem with the white race
according to a former Penn State
University at Abington Professor I
believe I was invited to speak at that
school and then the libs who run the
school shut that down I seem to recall
that this happens a number of times
every semester so I might be getting the
details blurry but I think it was this
school well this professor is uh Zach
de-pierro is suing the school for
discrimination on the basis of his race
say when he complained about the
continuous stream of racial insult
directed at White faculty in the writing
Department the director of the
affirmative action office told him that
quote there is a problem with the white
race that he should attend anti-racist
workshops until you get it
that he might have mental health issues
because he's white and didn't want to be
told that white people are evil all the
time and be treated like a second class
citizen
that is established in our law
and
I know that we're taught that white
people are the really privileged class
through the race at the top of the
social hierarchy but according to the
way the political order works in the
United States right now the opposite is
true I've said it on the show before and
I'll say it again white people
or one of two racial groups that you can
discriminate against on the basis of
college admissions and things like
employment and it's the only racial
group
that you can not only legally
discriminate against but also are
encouraged to socially discriminate
against and publicly insult
white people that's the group and so
this is obviously rather evil and white
people especially white liberals lap it
up because they've been infected with a
pandemic called white guilt something
that I don't feel I think it's because
the southern Italian swarthiness in me
has made me immune to such a disease
but
it's a major issue and conservatives
don't really want to talk about it
because being called a racist is still
the worst thing that you can be called
in the United States and even many
conservatives are still just terrified
of being called a racist so they don't
want to bring up anything that has
anything to do with racial grievance but
someone's gotta gotta answer this
okay and if the unit party and the
political establishment won't do it even
the you know
right-wing members of that political
establishment then some outside populist
candidate is going to do it in 2016
the libs naturally accused Donald Trump
being a racist and this was absolutely
Preposterous but Donald Trump was not
politically correct and he used language
that
if other candidates had used it they
would have been written off and set off
into the sunset as racist when he shows
up to go down the escalator and he says
I'm announcing my presidential campaign
because uh oh there are a lot of people
coming across the border in Mexico and
they're rapists and they're murderers
and they're terrible people but some I
assume are okay good people
and he said and also there are a lot of
places from failed Muslim countries
where you're getting terrorists coming
in here we're going to shut that down
and the the unit party said oh my
goodness he can't really say that and
Donald Trump
if Donald Trump is a racist I don't know
what racist means
he Donald Trump Donald Trump's been
featured in 300 rap songs right Donald
Trump is a mainstream pop culture figure
he's never displayed any racial animus
against anybody he's hugs everybody's
big friends with everybody for his whole
life and and so if if racist just means
you're willing to speak bluntly and and
you're not going to apologize for the
Grievous sin of being born with white
skin then okay I guess he he meets that
low threshold for racism but there are a
lot of people who say oh finally
I'm I'm not going to be called a monster
for the color of my skin this is what
impelled a much more polished candidate
like Glenn Younkin to win in Virginia
was two issues it was the gender
bathroom stuff and it was critical race
Theory
a Republican
really even a maybe a left-wing populist
candidate people who as the country is
becoming more divided between the many
and the few
populous candidates are going to have to
address this because this is deeply
unjust this is wrong we need to push for
the Supreme Court to overrule
affirmative action
and we need to lose it with the crazy
white guilt stuff and right now the the
leading candidate for that kind of
disruptive
attitude
is Donald Trump
and I know like some people are going to
say other candidates especially Rhonda
Santos
they could be better they should be
better at this
maybe maybe not we'll get into a little
bit tomorrow because I'm already over
time but right now that guy is the
leading candidate and that's why the
libs are so insistent that they've got
him now no member blocked today because
I don't know we're going all over the
place and these producer Danny won't get
me my iPad but we will have that back
tomorrow I'm Michael Moses Michael Mills
show see you then
[Music]